across America I'm talking about the mom
and pops your local diner the pizza
place the pasta joint and the three
Michelin star restaurant and honestly
everything in between and the things
that represent the cultural fabric of
our cities and of our towns and the
things that I believe as a country we
need to fight to keep we also represent
the 11 million people that work in those
independent restaurants across the
country listen
it's clear that this administration
cares about our industry and it's also
clear that all of you understand the
extent to which we are more specifically
vulnerable than a lot of other
industries in America and I think that's
why we're here today
and so I think it's just important to
take a moment and acknowledge that and
and say thank you that we're taking this
time thank you very much
PPP is important and the changes that
have already been talked about and are
gonna continue being talked about today
are very important and if those changes
are made such that people feel confident
that they can spend that money and have
it forgiven I think that will be the
thing that allows our restaurants to
reopen that said we need something more
than that that is specific to
independent restaurants in order for our
restaurants to stay open um everyone
here knows that last month alone I think
in the first half of April more than one
out of four people that applied for
unemployment were restaurant workers one
out of four
it's just insane and so we've put
forward to plan to members of Congress
into this administration that we put
forward because it'll put all of those
people that are currently unemployed
back to work such that by the third
quarter of this year we're gonna be
looking at unemployment reports that are
astonishingly good not to mention the
supply chain that we represent if
restaurants go down the commercial real
estate industry the farming industry and
so our plan helps bring unemployment
back to where it needs to be and it's of
course a lot of our and other industries
that rely on independents
for their survival and so we appreciate
being here we'd love the opportunity to
talk more about this I know that in
times like this a lot of people have
their hands out I don't take that
lightly
I do believe that independent
restaurants are more vulnerable than
most and a really important part of this
nation
and I don't want to lose them and so we
appreciate your consideration and your
support okay thank you very much we'll
appreciate it Larry please
forty-eight states are opening that's a
big plus and the vaccination research
news is great today so we see it in the
stock market I want to thank everybody
for being here we are working hard Steve
mentioned the tax deductions for
restaurants were also working very hard
on the kovat 19 liability restrictions
that's going to be a key part of our
next package and I just want to say I
guess I'm usually the optimist but we're
in a terrible pandemic contraction here
in the second quarter we know that
there's a lot of hardship and a lot of
heartbreak but there's also a few
glimmers of hope of recovery because I
know you sir believe in the second half
recovery and I do too and I think with
the right policies we can have a
blooming next year but the signs our
housing demand looks better gasoline
demand looks better the Apple mobility
index looks better that's you know
people dialing up to see who's where to
get from A to B New York State's Empire
State manufacturing index was up
enormous ly I don't know where that came
from but it was unemployment claims each
week looked terrible but they're a lot
less terrible from you know 7 million to
3 million so there are some glimmers of
hope Kevin has some data on better
credit card numbers so it's a tough haul
but I think things are starting to turn
that's my take wish our buddy luck I
think so Larry may be much more than
people understand and you starting to
see that gonna come back strong please
mr. president mr. vice president
secretary Scalia secretary I want to
thank you for having us here today I
have restaurants
the united states we average 27
employees per restaurant these are the
small businesses across in each of these
communities that those 27 people have
families have mortgages have rents have
car payments to make every day and being
able to stay open and work with the
governors and get the PPP money and to
be able to give people reassurances that
tomorrow is gonna be better than it was
today and to give them that hope has
been really important for us our
business and those families and I want
to thank you for your leadership and
your team's leadership in doing so one
of the things we talk about in the
business is how well we we talk about
treating others and bringing people into
the family and bring them into the
restaurant like you bring them into your
home and that's what we do in the
restaurant business
every day we treat everyone like family
and doing so and having the leadership
here has been really helpful to us and
the entire industry and frankly you know
eight weeks nine weeks ago I was
thinking about this Chinese nightmare
and I didn't want it to affect the
American Dream that we've all had and
and I'm a success story about the
American dream going from 3:45 an hour
starting at the front counter in a fast
food restaurant to what we have today
and I couldn't be proud of many how many
restaurants I own and operate 765
restaurants across the United States and
and it's I couldn't be
it's an American dream sir and I
appreciate everything everyone's doing
here to keep that dream going and the
tomorrow is gonna be better today and I
appreciate that thank you
if we get deductibility you'll do better
than you did two months ago
thank you sir that's my opinion please
give it just let us know what's going to
happen yeah sir
you know first of all you might recall
when we first started talking about the
economic damage that was coming from the
shutdown that we emphasized right from
the beginning that this industry and the
travel industry were going to be the
hardest hit and so we've been focused
like a laser beam on coming up with
policy ideas to do something about it
and as you said we've got a really good
plan the thing I could say is that if
you look at the real-time data as Larry
said that you really are starting to see
glimmers of hope
and maybe even like you could even have
characterized it a little more
optimistically than that Larry's being
super cautious but the credit card data
are really going up the number of
businesses open in the country is
skyrocketing I mean the country is
getting back now and I think that
there's a great reason for optimism for
this group because you can really see
things going much much faster forward
than I expected I I know you know I was
pretty depressed about how bad it looked
and how slow it was gonna be a few weeks
ago but now you can really see it
turning on faster than that yeah there's
a tremendous demand tremendous pent-up
demand it's true don't forget we turned
it off artificially you know it was just
stopped we went from the greatest
economy in history of any country to we
have to stop and we saved by doing that
millions of lives we saved hundreds of
thousands but probably millions of lives
and we did the right thing and now we
have to open and now we're going to do
great and if we if this comes along what
we're hearing
medically from these great companies
these great geniuses if this happens
that's really that's really gonna be
something so the great job thank you
because please mr. president mr. vice
president secretary Scalia secretary
minuchin it's an honor to be here today
my name is Marvin
Irby and on behalf of the National
Restaurant Association thank you for
convening this meeting these industry
leaders on this very important subject
to be honest with you normally at this
time I'd spend a lot of time telling you
about this industry but what's been
clear over the last several months is
that you get it this administration gets
it you know everything about our
world-famous chefs are esteemed
independence our beloved brands that dot
every community in this country and I'm
proud to say that for over 100 years the
National Restaurant Association has
represented all restaurants that play a
key role in our society an integral role
in our food chain I have the opportunity
that I get to speak to
trenchers every single day and I can
confirm we desperately want to reopen
our restaurants are desperate in our
heartbroken it at this time we can't
provide the support in the comfort to
the communities in which we serve for
too many restaurants right now this
incident happened sixty days ago that
has crippled us and before today's news
we did not see an end date until later
this year programs like the Paycheck
protection program are an incredible
first step and Thank You Secretary
phoenician for this program which has
benefited millions of small companies
throughout this country we also
appreciate Ivanka Trump's dedication to
our industry and I personally want to
thank you for the time you've taken to
talk to our board over the last month's
of this crisis mr. president the payroll
protection program would be a godsend if
we could make one change if we could
extend the time that we need that we
have to spend the proceeds in too many
communities today the eight week period
is simply not enough time so how much
how much time are you on about 30 weeks
30 weeks works there this works how
about 75 weeks I know a couple of you
you'll never stop right I know guys in
this room now I understand so you think
it needs to be what would you say would
be a minimum length 24 weeks how much 24
weeks you need to give our smaller
restaurants or is the opportunities to
open to begin to have demand and bring
back the employees is that what were you
gonna say in terms of timing yeah I
think for the PPP fixes if we could take
it from eight weeks to 24 weeks is that
don't know is that the chair yeah more
or less the term you think and then move
June 30th to October 31st
if those two changes were made to that
program
it would change it dramatically what's
more important that or deductibility
that yes deductibility is amazing but
it's almost like we need to build the
house first detectability is the thing
that makes the house does anybody
disagree with that because I think
deductibility is the biggest thing you
can possibly do mr. Sonny I think that
if you if what he's saying is if we
could get the 24 weeks which gets us to
October 31st basically right this allows
us to to get the young restaurant tours
going and spend the money that you
intended for them so that we can get out
and show them what a great job you guys
are doing but you're pretty unified on
the number 24 well yes there's no
additional money it's an extension of
the current program okay so the
deductibility thing is great I just
don't want to not support that I think
it's just a matter of waiting we need to
get the restaurants open first and these
changes allow us to get them open I just
want to clarify but you said it's no
additional money are you saying just the
time period because it's eight weeks
going to 24 you still have eight weeks
of money or you want 24 weeks of money
oh no we want 24 weeks in order to spend
to spend the eight weeks correct got it
thank you for the clarification we
believe that if we elongate is that
correct does everybody agree with it yes
sir if we can elongate the test period
it gives us more staying power and we
can spend that money and really get
where we need to be good so and what
about the payroll tax by the way how do
you feel about that is that a big deal
yes sir that would be an extraordinarily
big deal yes and how does that compare
with what we're talking about with the
time period payroll tax I would say
deductibility payroll tax deductions all
those things are spectacular and we need
them and they would be greatly
beneficial but we're viewing the pay
peak the PPP fix as what we need
so the be popu was really a big deal yes
sir
so we hit it right while we did it we
hit it
okay thank you very much am i doing
wrong it was such a big deal sir that we
haven't laid off a single person and
there's 20,000 people that are paying
their taxes they're paying their bills
and they're doing all that every day and
without that I don't think we would have
been able to do that sir that's how big
a deal it is it's great
mr. president mr. vice president good
afternoon thank you so much for your
leadership ladies and gentlemen it's an
honor to be here and I deeply appreciate
the opportunity my name is marina
represent Panera Bread Panera has two
and a half thousand cafes revenues of
about six billion dollars and we employ
a hundred and forty thousand people the
pandemic impacted us very deeply as I
did everybody else
we lost close to 50% of our revenue in
the first week since then it is slowly
coming back but we still have a long way
to go now the health crisis you got down
by 50% or more than that 50 to 60% was a
revenue decline that's not bad and we
are and I think what's what's good is
that it's actually coming back since
that diet thanks to a lot of the
innovation that we've been able to do
good so you got maximum there 50% of
revenue loss yeah how do you keep the
other 50% so the the 50% that we have by
insuring so fortunately I think and
Panera we have very strong omni-channel
business so we have delivery rapid
pickup drive-through you did very well
so on that's yeah great job yeah so I
think we've had to innovate very quickly
and I'll share some some of those ideas
so I believe that the health crisis is
now becoming a financial crisis you know
with 36 million Americans unemployed and
a humanitarian crisis as well
with about 54 million Americans fighting
hunger and therefore I think opening up
the economy right now in a phased manner
is the right thing to do I also believe
that we as leaders need to also step up
and do the right thing as
Stein and do what we can do what's in
our control and I'll share some ideas
and thoughts in terms of what Panera has
been doing largely with the intent to
innovate and do that with compassion and
heart so for our followed employees you
know we have free family meals every
week for them emergency relief funds and
also we've made arrangements with beer
companies that are actually hiring at
this time like CVS Walmart to hire our
followed employees temporarily and then
return them back for customers we've
innovated very quickly we've launched
the curbside pickup service with
geofencing and also free Wi-Fi outside
the cafes because life is moving to
outside the cafes and also doing a lot
for our communities especially those
impacted most by the pandemic so doctors
and nurses we are serving about 50,000
meals to doctors and nurses in New York
children in the state of Ohio with our
partnership with USDA and also we've
launched a program called together
without hunger with feeding America and
have blessed to serve half a million
meals to children and families through
through feeding America right so I think
it's very important at this time that I
think we need to also step up and
contribute we were able to keep 85
percent of her cafes open we were
determined to give them opens that we
could keep our associates employed at
that time and therefore now we're
beginning to open up the dining areas
and phases following all the guidelines
but we also have stringent protocols
that we've put in place like Plexiglas
barriers wellness stations for
temperature checks social distancing
norms etc I think keeping any of that I
mean there are some innovations that
have been made some people say maybe
we'll keep it would you be keeping any
of that or not really yes we I think
this is there's gonna be a shift in how
the consumers are going to interact with
brands and I think it is time for us to
innovate so what another example is
would you ever keep the Plexiglas
barriers so I think we keep the
Plexiglas barriers on a permanent basis
I'm talking about I think at least over
the next six to nine months but could
you see that being permanent because
hopefully you're not gonna have to have
it that long by the way nine months but
would you see the thing like
that you'd have to build a nicer version
of it ever you know as opposed to
quickly throwing it up but would you see
something like that being permanent
possibly I think hopefully if the virus
is an under control and we've gotten to
the other side of it and then we can
better get back to life as we once knew
you'd rather not have it we'd rather
move back to life as we wants to read
rather not I agree yeah I agree
exactly okay another I think interesting
innovation is that recognizing that this
saw so much high friction with high
demand grocery items where you can't get
them home delivered we launched a new
line of business called Panera grocery
in ten days and we're delivering you
know bakery items fresh produce dairy to
customers in less than an hour on the
same day so I think the good thing is
it's forced us to really innovate and be
very responsive I think there is
restaurant industry is deeply deeply
appreciative of all the support and the
efforts that you and the administration
have made I think the Gas Act has been
hugely welcomed I would like to in
particular thank you for the PPP program
because it's made a huge difference to
our franchise partners and our
associates I think with a few of the
amendments that we talked about that
fully agree with the eight weeks or 24
weeks I think that is badly needed I
think that will be hugely welcomed Steve
does that make sense from our standpoint
what do you think we're working on a
technical fix that we do have bipartisan
support for to extend it I'm not sure
it's that long but I've spoken to the
SBA committee and there is bipartisan
support so were working on that I think
we talked about the limited liability I
think that's also very important aspect
and thirdly the Democrats don't want to
give you a July body provision they just
don't want to have that and it's crazy
that they don't but the Democrats do not
want to give that to people and that's
not a good thing and I think the the
third thing anyway go ahead
the our employees are I think if we can
eliminate the friction in the forward
employees being able to access the
unemployment benefits that will also be
fantastic and and that the problem there
is the states have old equipment in many
cases and they're unable to get the
money you know we gave the money out
immediately but the states are oh no
some states are unable to give it out
their 40-year old equipment yeah and
some states are unable to get their act
together
but we gave that out long ago as you
probably know yeah okay I appreciate it
thank you very much thank you very much
Brooke would you like to say a few words
mr. president thank you just a few words
I am I am so grateful for all of you
being here today I am struck by the
stories of true American dreams I mean
starting at 3:45 an hour and then
ultimately owning so many restaurants
and hundreds of thousands but I'm also
hundreds of thousands of employees but
I'm also struck by this president and
vice president's commitment to our most
vulnerable populations and their
American Dream and their American Dream
working in all of your restaurants this
president is the jobs president I think
that none of us other than maybe my boss
realized the economy that we would
achieve in just three short years where
there were more people realized the
economy that we would achieve in just
three short years where there were more
people more jobs available than people
to fill them and what I am so encouraged
by is the resoluteness and the
conviction of this president this vice
president but but truly the American
entrepreneurs that are sitting around
the table today and working alongside
all of you as we bring this country back
to even greater heights than we ever
knew possible the transition to
greatness is is really what America and
the American Dream is all about so thank
you all for being here know that we are
here to help you always and we are here
to make sure that what this president
led on and has achieved will be once
again very very soon so thank you mr.
president you very much for a great job
Thank You mr. president mr. vice
president and secretaries for having me
here today
my name is Tim love I'm a chef and owner
of a few restaurants in Texas and
Tennessee I also am the chef of four
major music festivals and food festivals
around the country so I've been greatly
affected by obviously what's happened
here along with everybody else in this
room but what I wanted to speak to you
about today is that to touch on the PPP
and to kind of clarify with what we were
saying is the 24 weeks is only set up
because certain restaurants aren't able
to open now in Texas we were able to
open on May 1st
and I quickly activated the PPP and
tried to get on my employees back I've
hired 80% of my workforce I started with
four hundred nine employees we've got
about 400 employees already back and I
will say it's encouraging to see people
come out they're excited they want to be
out what would have happened if you
didn't have PPP well if I didn't have
survived it would you've gotten by I
probably have gotten by but that this
allows us to do it the way that we feel
like it should be to take care of the
employees first we want to take care of
our employees and make sure they're safe
same-same activation we're having
opening the restaurants we want to open
the restaurant safely make sure our
employees are safe first started guests
can be safe I asked from the
administration to put out that
confidence to get the American people
understanding that it is great to go out
and that our economy is going to be
great again because we know where it was
before it started we know how to get
there clearly so now just with a couple
of adjustments to things that are
already written now you to the
Secretary's point we don't need and
we're not asking for more money we're
assessing an opportunity to spend it the
way that you want to suspend it the way
it was intended to take care of our
employees when we're able to open up
that's it
yes sir mr. president I think I think
you can you can take care of that sure
it should be easy yeah and like one of
the easiest requests I've ever heard
there it's a half that that leads me to
my knees my next requests the 7525 the
way that it's spent I know it's tough
but I'm speaking for my friends who are
in New York not necessarily for myself
even in Texas where the rents are higher
and they need the ability to spend the
money on rent if necessary so long as
they're hiring their employees back so
while the number one thing is to get the
workforce back reduce unemployment get
people back to work which is what I'm
doing at 25 percent believe me I'm not
going and building new houses on my 25
percent of occupancy but what I am doing
is putting the great American people
back to work that I love and the way we
get the economy going is getting the
workers back to work so they're able to
spend money and earn money so therefore
we can keep the economy moving and so
those two adjustments to the PPP which
which you know don't require any extra
money from the administration from
Congress allows us
to really move the economy for which I
noticed one of your number one things
especially as we're moving along this
year and I think you can get a lot of
people in our industry the workers that
people work very very hard to get behind
you just to show that kind of confidence
I think you will how many restaurants
are there total everything in the United
States how many other how much six
hundred and fifty thousand residents who
would think that's 11 percent of the
overall 650,000 restaurants who would
ever think that's possible even right
that's good and it's been a great
business over the years and it'll be
better the 650 thousand again so Longy I
think deductibility gets that actually I
think you'll I would agree with that
very substantially they got rid of a lot
of restaurants when they ended that
people don't realize that then you get
used to again fewer restaurants they
rented to other things now I don't know
what they're gonna rent to and to your
point about that sir that the
deductibility which you can easily
identify with and it and it does spread
wealth amongst restaurants most
definitely we're talking just about an
immediate concern with the PPP to get
people moving forward so that my guys
deductibility going well look at that
very strongly yes sir thank you okay
hello mr. president and it sees how
important this it is to all of you all
this subject because I haven't seen this
much firepower from all of y'all except
at a state dinner or a Christmas party
so I appreciate mr. president that all
of you guys are here because I know
you're really trying to get something
done I own a company landries which is
in 40 states and it's all full-service
restaurants so I averaged
like 150 employees per restaurant and
it's everything from Dell Frisco's to
Mastro's to Martin's the palm but then
it's on the other side the Bubba Gump's
the rain forest and and they're all
company owned this it's been devastating
and it's you know it's funny you brought
up about China I should have realized it
was gonna be a bad year for China when
my general manager tweeted out you know
freedom for Hong Kong so that started my
year with riot right
so so I'm still trying to work that out
and here comes something I don't see
Euston rockets and it's a great and by
the way is a great guy great family
great everything and yeah he did cause
you little ruckus did whatever happened
to him yeah so working for you yes he is
you must be pretty guest because it's
just it's a trick question anybody is so
but but but mister president
everybody's talking about the PPP and
the when when your team designed the PPP
and said let's bring it through through
the SBA I think it was an unbelievable
idea and and you did exactly what you
needed to do but I'm one of those people
when it started being pitted against
because I'm a sole proprietor but I do
four billion in revenue and I would have
been that billionaire that took the
money from the little business so I was
not able to take the PPP money and I
caught so much criticism because I was
the first person who did layoffs forty
thousand employees because the world
doesn't understand that when you shut
everything down from your casinos which
you and I did a few deals together from
the rainforests of the Trump marina your
tail of your payroll was one hundred and
fifty million dollars the next two weeks
and we all pay
yesterday's bills with today's income
and and I wanted to put 40,000 people
back to work May the first but couldn't
take the the criticism and even from the
administration that was something that
bigger companies shouldn't be taking
this money but but I don't have the
ability to put those 40,000 people back
to work so I just wished that don't add
any money but just divide it up so
you're saying that because your
restaurants aren't split up among
thousands of people that own restaurants
and you have it yourself in the yeah
that it would have been one person
taking this money but using but your
team specifically wrote the bill for any
restaurant under
five hundred it this was for the
restaurant business yeah which has only
gotten nine percent of the money but if
you would just split it up and I'm not
saying add any more money
but at a category for the the larger
private restaurant tour that could go
out and take this money and put it in a
different bucket so it wouldn't be me
taking this money away from the little
beauty so what happened to you then
Tillman so where are you on that whole
thing how did you do with the rupee how
did you how did it work out for your
company I took the money and sent it
back and did not spend a dollar of it
because they found out you're very rich
and they said what the hell you know
what but also was the first person that
opened the leveraged finance market and
went and borrowed three hundred million
yeah at twelve percent we're just three
months earlier borrowed at three percent
because I needed that a liquidity to
keep the company afloat so so what do
you do you went out very early right for
the money and you you found the market
were it was opened even at that early
days yes I'm borrowing to add to
liquidity but I still it wasn't enough
to to hire back all my employees which I
would have loved have done with the PPP
way to do with your basketball players
that are making twenty five million a
year I have two of them that make forty
Russell and James by the way they are
good players they are good but they yes
they are getting paid bargaining
agreement and that's what's gonna happen
with basketball can you give us a
because I would be interested you have
any idea what they're doing now yes yes
I think what they're doing is is waiting
to see what happens in certain states
and if we're going to be able to play
making sure that virus continues to go
and they're in the right direction in
the next few weeks and and I think that
if things keep going the way that it's
going I think the NBA the Commissioner
Adam Silver who's done an unbelievable
job through this and and the thirty the
owners I think will make the decision to
try to start the season up again will
you finish the season or not I think
that there's talk about finishing the
season playing X amount of
gains the the players need to play to to
get paid and right now they're taking a
twenty five percent pay cut and because
they they own fifty percent of our
revenues the players unlike the other
sports and so they they want that
revenue and that television revenue even
if it's not that the people in the
stands revenue so they can get paid
could you go immediately to playoffs or
is that not really possible I think that
they would use the I think that we would
play some games just to get it going
again I create the interest and then go
right into the playoffs but I think
it'll be great for America we're all
missing sports and everybody you know
wants to see these great NBA teams but
good luck with it thank you
but just create a category for us mr.
secretary well Steve what do you think
about that I mean he's got a unique
situation you know he has a lot of
restaurants it's a big company but but I
can't pay have other people where the
company is the same size but you have
two thousand owners what do you think of
that well it's a complicated issue mr.
president as I said before we we didn't
anticipate the Los Angeles Lakers who
I'm a big fan of would be taking a PPP
loan and as a result of that there was a
lot of backlash all right paid it back
we went through this I'm saying that for
the median they again we realized the
issue how it impacts your workers and
we're sympathetic to that this was a
program for companies that we're not
necessarily quite as big but this is
different than the Lakers the Lakers are
a basketball team there's a man that
owns many how many restaurants you are
six hundred restaurants but they're all
full-service restaurants you know I have
60,000 employees and and and you don't
have the ability to pay them I'm happy
to follow up with you we don't need to
have this and in front no but it is
interesting for the press to hear
because they understand the complexity
of it so if he had 600 owners and he
franchised them out or something but he
had 600 owners they qualify if he has
you know if he owns it it's a different
situation but I can understand what he's
saying so
let's take a look at it and then just
one more thing if we could just do
something with lease terminations
because like I'm the largest operator in
New York for full-service restaurants
and the million dollar leases let them
protect their rights the land what's
your largest restaurant what is it
Dell Frisco's Mastro's Morton's to strip
house the the Bill's burger and
Rockefeller Center
you know Dos Caminos you know on and on
so but but if if we could job you've
done I mean they got hit by the plague
right but outside of that you've done a
hell of a job just trying to keep up
just brought you back to earth a little
bit we were definitely brought back to
earth you really have you've done a
fantastic job mate you're a friend of
mine for a long time and thank you safe
to say you paid me rent for a long time
right absolutely never missed anything
and you were never late now your tummy
great gentleman really a great gentleman
see if it's an interesting case okay do
the best you can good luck with a
basketball thank you sir you have a hell
of a team and thank all of you say hello
to those two great players all of your
players but man they are they can play
huh they can play so you say they make
40 a year
Russell and James both make 40 million a
year and they were still getting paid so
a lot of my employees really wanted that
PPP money you want them to you want them
to play this year yes sir how many more
years you have together right so you
have both of them for three you want
them to play this year because magic can
happen right absolutely a little magic
and good luck sudden you get a big ring
thanks to me thank you sir okay I just
want to thank everyone for being here
it's been incredible to watch all the
innovations that you've been doing in
your business models to give more
confidence to the public to get open the
president identified this very early as
a critical industry for us to focus on
for a few reasons one is you're a major
employer there's a lot of people who are
hurting right now because the restaurant
industry is closed but also you're a gem
of America people love getting
entertainment and enjoyment from the
great work that you do so this has never
really been an issue before because the
restaurant business has never been
closed before for a period of time so
this is truly a unique historical
situation that's occurred and you know
we're all in this together
to figure out the best way back but the
quicker that we can help you figure out
how to get demand up the quicker you
could hire back employees and we can get
Americans back to enjoying all of your
fine establishment so thank you for all
you're doing and thank you mr. president
for your leadership so you know Tillman
he took a ventilator job where the
country basically had no ventilators
essentially and built an incredible
empire for building ventilators in a
period of very short time and now we're
supplying ventilators all over the world
it's an amazing thing we got no credit
from the fact is medieval what are you
gonna do can't win em all and now the
testing today on the Washington Post
they actually had a headline that the
testing is there but the people aren't
that we have so much testing I'm sure
the person that drew that headline in
the Washington Post will be fired today
sometimes in the study that in the state
of Texas I know four for six weeks any
employee of mind could go to numerous
places and get tested and not even stand
in line so when I watch and see
everything that people cannot get tested
in America and I don't know about all
the other states but I do have employees
that have been tested in other states I
just follow it closer there has not been
an issue of people getting tested and
you know they sort of knew it and we
were even tested here so yeah I think
you should be entitled to the now Steve
[Laughter]
yeah no we're done really it's been
another percent did an amazing job been
an amazing job we made a lot of
Governors look good I will say yesterday
you had your number one day in America
422,000 test performed and you're about
eleven and a half million tests
performed down the u.s. thanks to your
leadership numbers that would have been
unthinkable I think you could say that
right numbers that would have been John
those are numbers that could have been
talked about nobody would have believed
it so anyway you know so please mr.
president like yourself I'm a New Yorker
and a career changer as a former bond
trader at Goldman Sachs and now I own
restaurants in Brooklyn most notably
Lilia and Missy in Williamsburg we help
make every day good day along with
Thomas and will
we're founding members of the
independent restaurant coalition and
we're grateful to have a seat at this
table for the first time the impact
catalyzed by this pandemic is enormous
the prolonged economic shutdown created
challenges for our industry that has to
be met with policy to inject liquidity
investment consumption and hiring the
immediate and coordinated response by
your administration to support
out-of-work employees was inspiring and
it should make us all proud to be
Americans the intention of PPP to
support small businesses and restaurants
was pragmatic and encouraging we have
all agreed that it wasn't perfect but
we're working on it
to fix it so that it could help us but
we need those fixes now like me I have
it I can't use it I'm in the clock zone
of eight weeks PPP is a bridge so do you
agree with what they're saying in terms
of timing immediately they must have you
agree with the twenty-four number yes
absolutely did you guys meet before this
or something
no did you have a little meeting to
discuss this per piece well now I feel
better because everyone's exactly what
is the same thing what is ink what is
incredible about this independent
restaurant coalition this did not exist
seven weeks ago
restaurant owners didn't talk to each
other ever and we want to bring people
together you've seen that in government
I bring the Democrats together with the
Republicans right and it was it's been a
beautiful thing I'm only kidding we've
anyway we've been able to talk we'd be a
bit any book be creative and figure out
ways to bring this that's great I think
it's great you got together and a lot of
good suggestions have been made and it's
been made uniformly so we really know
your opinion as opposed to having mold
it for an idea that's correct that's
really great so PPP is a bridge it will
help restaurants reopen our doors
it'll help restaurants re-employ 11
million workers that are currently not
working in an effort to keep those doors
open and to keep our people employed we
propose a stabilization plan and we look
forward to discussing more in the future
with you
okay thank you very much thank you great
how'd you go from Goldman Sachs to the
restaurant business how did that happen
David Solomon didn't think I was very
good at bond trading but you were I'll
bet you were very good are you glad you
made that move I am it's changed my life
for the better on every every meal of
the restaurant business I love it I have
friends are in the restaurant they love
the rest there's no business they want
to go into we view you as one of us yeah
once we do yeah no it's great I know
your business very well people unlike
well you know there are other businesses
but just about as much as any business
they love being in the restaurant
business so that's great it's it's good
to get out of there so you made a good
move oh yes did you make a good move
financially I did very very well it
worked out fine too our restaurants are
more profitable than the hedge fund that
I worked at for saving Wow that's
fantastic
yes now we don't have to give them
anything but but but I want to go back
to that because I want to reopen as soon
as possible yeah I agree with it okay
great good good job - I know the one
restaurant I know it's great thank you
very much Jean there's a man of great
jeans his name is Jean and his father
was a terrific gentleman you know that
right great talent a great mother -
right maybe your mother's even better
well there are a few industries where
the workers have been hit as hard as in
this particular industry as well was
touching on we announced twenty point
five million payroll job losses
basically from the middle of March in
the middle of April and 5.5 million of
those more than a quarter were in
restaurants
mr. president you saw this coming you
acted with really extraordinary speed
and I think as we said generosity among
other things in the unemployment benefit
that was provided in the Kerr's Act we
at the Labor Department have been
working extremely hard with the states
to enable them to make that payment as
you touched on they've had they've had
some problems because of their computer
systems which are old secretary Manucci
and I cautioned the Congress that there
would be problems but we will continue
to work with them to get those payments
out but but even as we do that we know
that we're pivoting we're opening we're
reopening across the country it's it is
there
our glimmers and more than that as we
begin that reopening and so we will be
focusing to on helping workers
transition from unemployment back on to
the job and you hear a lot of numbers a
number that really sticks with me is a
couple different surveys have shown
federal surveys have shown that ninety
percent of workers who are unemployed
right now have said it's temporary and I
want to make that right I want to make
that true that's why mr. president you
want to safely but but promptly reopen
and so we'll continue to work with
that's a very important number it's
ninety percent you go into a real big
recession and you don't have a number
like that that's a tremendous number
that's really a great it says it's a
testament because again it was
artificially turned on and off but now
it's off and we're gonna turn it back on
it's been turned on as of I don't know
it almost feels like today's the first
day I think last week didn't feel the
same now it feels good people are
starting to go out they're opening they
get it we understand the disease much
better than we did when it first came in
nobody understood it nobody's ever seen
it before and it feels much different I
mean today's almost like the first day
but the expression that we like to use
right transition to greatness we're
going to be back and what you said is a
very important thing people expect to go
back and buy moving quickly but safely
we get them there and I had discussions
with several of you about about safety
we're very focused on that at the Labor
Department giving workers and I know
you're focused to and giving customers
and confidence as they return and we'll
we'll continue to work with CDC and
others to help on that front and gene
you have to help the trucker's also
we've been talking about as mr.
president I've been out there and I'll
tell you there they work hard and they
have brokers that take a lot of their
business away they don't work so hard
they sit in an office someplace it's not
good so I'd like to help the trucker's
yeah Elaine and I have been talking all
right good please mr. president
secretary moochin vice president pence
said great Scalia thank you for having
us here today of course I'll echo what
everybody else has said how proud we are
to be sitting here at the White House in
your home to be able to share some of
our struggles and
and hopes and aspirations the restaurant
profession is a profession that's always
dynamic and you've seen that around this
table with some of the things that my
colleagues are doing but we're also very
United as you've seen and you just
responded to the 24 weeks did we have a
meeting before certainly we had a
meeting before did we talk about it
certainly we talked about it because we
want to be unified in our approach
whether you have 650 restaurants two
restaurants six restaurants thousand
restaurants it doesn't really matter we
all are nurturers at heart and we want
our restaurants to reopen so that they
can nurture our guests our communities
and finally our country there's
something to be said for going last
because I just want to agree with
everything that everybody else has said
around this table so I won't
I won't repeat it and Boris with with
more of the same but I will tell you a
story of personal story to personal
stories if I may one about the PPP and
thank you very much because it's been a
lifesaver in many ways for me I have
restaurants of course where I have not
been able to use the PPP yet but I also
have because we can't open yet and
there's no point in me hiring back one
step where California New York Las Vegas
and South Florida I mean I hear they're
gonna keep Los Angeles close till the
end of August is that a fact
that's a good question I'm in Napa
Valley but I'm not really sure about Los
Angeles I'm sorry that's the mayor wants
to do that that's a death wish because
you know there's death on both sides you
know that there's death on both sides
not just a one-way street and we solved
a big problem but you have to understand
the other side of it too and they don't
understand the other side of it yep on
the other hand our consumer product good
division where we have four different
businesses has been thriving and we have
taken our PPP money and and rehired a
hundred percent of the staff in those
four companies so I I look at that and
I'm extremely thankful and grateful for
all the work that you and your team have
done
so quickly to help us on our restaurant
side I echo what everybody else is
that's it's a little more more
complicated I also want to thank you for
voicing your support of big which is our
business interruption group which I
started with a couple other chefs and
has grown quite large and we start to
make some inroads with with the
insurance companies certainly with some
of the congressman's and some of the
senators so we continue to work on that
for all businesses not just for
restaurant businesses finally I want to
talk about a small farm in Orwell
Vermont's a small farmer named dining
Saint Clair who is by herself with her
husband and this is about the supply
chain and how important restaurants are
in in in so many different aspects but
we reduce it down to individuals that we
know that we love that depend on us as
as restaurant tours and as chefs as a
woman who has eight cows who gets up
every morning seven days a week to milk
or cows let him out the pasture begin to
make her butter we're here cows back at
four or five o'clock milk them again and
put them to bed every day I am I am the
sole source of her revenue she's not
able to sell her butter anywhere else so
she's not making butter today the impact
that restaurants have in our in our
communities in our states and in our
country are extraordinary we are in many
cases the first job people have my first
job was in a restaurant as a dishwasher
making a little less than 350 but that
was bisque of my age and and being able
to move up we are the we give people the
second chance in restaurants and finally
people's last jobs are in restaurants
those who are retired and on and on and
on benefits are augmenting their
benefits by working in restaurants we
don't really care about your education
we're not concerned about where you come
from
your religious beliefs we are open to
everybody we employ the most women of
anybody beside the federal government
the most single-parent women's it's just
extraordinary how how much we embrace
our entire country and what we do and
what we do at heart is we nurture I
became a chef and I remember the day I
decided to become a chef I'd been
cooking for several years July in 1977
and Narragansett Rhode Island working
for a French chef named Rowland Henin
who asked me one day why do cooks cook
and I was certainly intimidated I was
young and as a chef I don't know why
don't why do cooks cook
he said we cooked in nurture people and
there was something inside of me that
that resonated with and I embraced the
idea and nurturing people and I have
1,200 employees there are over eleven
hundred and eighty who are unemployed
today that I desperately want to bring
back to work so that we can not only
nurture each other or nurture those who
come into our restaurants again I want
to thank you for for having us here
today I want to thank all my colleagues
for for articulating everything that we
wanted to say in in in in such a
profound way and I appreciate the
opportunity so Thank You mr. president
thank you very much beautiful story with
the woman with the eight cows wouldn't
think that Restaurant tours do
especially I guess some with an
individual restaurant or a couple of
restaurants they do that a lot don't
they they buy directly they do yeah we
support so many small farms around the
country I started an initiative called
big hearts and small farms with five
other chefs just so that we can offer
people an opportunity to buy some of the
some of the food from some of these
small farms around the country Tilman
doesn't do that I don't think you do
that with you eight cows right
it's a little different but it goes from
there very small to the very big and
that's what the restaurants were all
about and I'm proud to be part of this
community what's the difference in
butter tell me the difference in butter
between what she sells you and what you
would normally be able to buy at a Giri
I don't want it it is extraordinary
because it is truly a seasonal product
so the butter changes flavor in color
depending on the season so and there
early in the spring when they're eating
green when they're grazing on grass or
grass the butter is at spendable orange
hue and of course in the summer time it
turns lighter because they're eating
Hays and Mike is no comparison he knows
it's tremendous a tremendous difference
in well I don't know how much I pay it's
not about how much I pay it's about
supporting her and what she's trying to
do but would you pay less generally
speaking when you do those things you do
directly with the floor you know when we
deal directly with the farmers is that
why never talk about price
it's always about quality and building
relationships with people building wood
I've been buying Diane's butter for over
20 years no kid she she did tell me I'll
tell you a little story again if I can
that she had to raise the price of her
butter and I said Diane I really don't
know how much your butter cost but I
appreciate you telling me this issues
but I also want to tell you why and I
said okay tell me why Diane she said my
son was accepted at NYU and I need to
pay for his tuition this is what happens
when a guest goes into a restaurant and
spends a dollar
you're supporting all of these people
you're supporting this young man who's
gonna get a degree from NYU do I to buy
a should I said should I you know
negotiate with her on price yeah no I
think it's great thank you very much
beautiful well thank you mr. president
and I have had the great privilege of
sitting in this room alongside the
president many occasions over the last
three and a half years I don't know that
I've
ever been more inspired by the optimism
the resilience the love of what you do
and the people that you employ and the
people that you serve than I've been
today so thank you all for sharing your
stories president has brought together
here that our top economic team
secretary of the Treasury Secretary of
the Labour all the people that have been
involved in standing up the whole of
government response but from the
standpoint of the White House
coronavirus task force let me just say
thank you in this industry 650,000
restaurants strong had to make very very
hard choices I want to assure you you
said sean's that you all considered the
president to be one of you and I can
tell you my friend considers himself to
be one of you and he always will and but
he understood when we asked the American
people and we asked businesses like the
thousands represented here to shut down
to to go to drive-through services to
find ways to innovate to meet your
customers we knew the sacrifices that
were involved in that the president
directed our economic team to find a way
Paycheck protection to stand up and come
alongside but your decision your
company's decision to put the health of
your employees the health of your
customers the health of your community
first saved lives and you are to be
commended on behalf of the president and
all of us have worked seven days a week
on this issue here at the national level
I want to say thank you president are
going to dismiss in a few minutes and
we're going to go to our weekly call
with America's governors and I'm proud
as the president is that as we sit here
today forty-eight states have announced
plans to reopen it was a month ago the
president had our task force release a
plan to open up America again in America
is opening back up and I just want to
assure you that the council that you
have given us today will continue to
inform ways that we can support not just
this industry and the communities but
support your state's efforts to safely
and responsibly reopen and put them
there
back to work one last thing mr.
president one of the great success
stories of this pandemic has been that
the food supply has not been interrupted
and I honestly didn't know mr. president
before we got into this that roughly
half of America's food needs are met in
restaurants and in those 650,000
establishments that we were talking
about here today and through this
pandemic not only did you innovate you
found ways to continue to meet that food
need and keep food on the table of
Americans but I also heard just a week
ago that it was restaurants that were
transferring what you had in storage to
your local grocery stores to your local
food banks to make sure that Americans
didn't miss any meals in the course of
this pandemic so for all those reasons I
say thank you and just know that in this
president and in this entire team we are
going to be partners with you and we're
gonna bring back America and all of
America's great restaurants bigger and
better than ever before and it's gonna
be sooner than you think Mike what are
the two states that did not open 48
states have released plans there's two
that are we expect them to be releasing
plans very soon I'll get that to you
before we talk to the governors is
Connecticut is and do anything so hello
it'll happen quickly so just briefly the
Paycheck protection program has
delivered over 30 billion dollars in aid
to more than 250,000 restaurants up to
95 percent of that funding is going
directly to the workers payroll you know
that on Friday the SBA published the
loan forgiveness application which
ensures that all businesses including
restaurants will not be penalized as
long as they make good-faith efforts to
rehire all of their employees you know
that I signed a bill providing federally
funded pay to sick people people that
are sick and for family leave so you
have for sick and family leave and
that's very important bill so you have
federally funded
paid sick and family leave and I think
some of you are taking advantage of that
businesses can defer paying income taxes
until July 15th we gave that extension
business can claim tax refunds by
deducting their losses from the 2018
through 2020 against taxes they paid for
the previous five years it's a big deal
and then as you know we're going to
Congress and this is more pertinent to
what we're talking because you knew all
of what I just said you've been living
through it restore the restaurant
deduction to help jobless restaurant
workers so if a company pays or somebody
pays they get a deduction that's going
to create a tremendous amount of
business I think you're gonna have to
open a lot of additional restaurants in
this country I think it's frankly more
important than even the other things
we're talking about it gets short-term
what you're talking about is more
important but long-term the deduction
would be phenomenal create and explore
America that's explore right
exploreamerica Tax Credit that Americans
can use for domestic travel including
visits to restaurants that's a big deal
Grint restaurants more flexibility under
the PPP that's what we're talking about
right and protect workers and businesses
alike with curbs on frivolous litigation
frivolous litigation a thing I know
something about there's a lot of
frivolous litigation so we don't want
somebody going and sitting in your
restaurant
Tilman and then suing you for ten
million dollars because something
happened they do it anyway
no matter what we give you they're gonna
do it anyway you know that so I thank
you all for being here we'll take a
couple of questions John and if you have
any questions for these great restaurant
to us please ask oh well mr. president
first a question for you Attorney
General Barr says he is unlikely to have
any criminal investigation of either
Barack Obama or Jill Biden you've been
talking about what you call the greatest
political crime in American history what
do you think of mr. Bars decision well I
think it was me they would do it I think
for them maybe they're not going to I
don't know I'm surprised because Obama
knew everything that was happening I
don't think Obama knows where he where
he you know is in a lot of ways I saw
his statements the other day and I think
that frankly they weren't very good
that's President Obama as far as
items concerned I can't that I can't
tell you only he knows what he knows I
don't think he knows too much but I
think Obama and Biden knew about it they
were participants but so I'm a little
surprised by that statement I don't
think he said it quite the way you said
it I think he said as of this moment I
guess but if it was me I guarantee
they'd be going after me in his case
they're not so I think it's just a
continuation of a double standard I'm
surprised by it I'm surprised by it but
that's where it is and I don't know what
he said about this you have to
understand I was coming into this room
as that statement was being made so I
think interesting he said we cannot
allow this process the legal process to
be hijacked by efforts to drum up
criminal allegations investigations of
either candidate he seemed to be
suggesting why I think you'd have to ask
him what that means because I'm in no
position to tell you that I've stayed
away from it I'm relying on the Attorney
General to do the job and so I don't
know exactly what he said because I was
in this room it's appointed if there is
no criminal investigation of Biden or
Obama disappointed or not but I have no
doubt that they were involved in this
hoax one of the worst things ever to
befall this country in terms of
political scandal I have absolutely no
doubt that Obama and Biden were involved
and as to whether or not it was criminal
I would think it would be very serious
very very serious it was a takedown of a
president regardless of me it happened
to be me and in my opinion it was an
illegal takedown and but I'm gonna let
the Attorney General make all of those
decisions I've stayed out of it because
it's the appropriate thing to do I
wouldn't have to stay out of it as you
know but I've decided to stay out of it
so I would say that I heard that just a
little while ago a few minutes ago off
to look at it exactly as to what was
said what was meant I will say this we
have an honorable attorney general he's
going to do an honorable job he's a very
honorable man and he's going to do a
very honorable job but I am surprised
only in that I have no
personally I have no doubt but he may
have another feeling I have no doubt
that they were involved in it it's a
hoax it started off with a Russian hoax
they went to a Ukraine hoax it's just a
whole big disgrace and this country has
better things to do it's a disgrace what
they've done to this country with these
phony investigations the Muller
investigation was a waste of time from
day one they knew it was a waste of time
it proved to be a waste of time I think
they're a lot of bad people involved and
they should pay a very big price if they
were caught so we'll see what happens
but I rely on the attorney general he's
a very honorable man okay any other
questions
Peter Navarro who sent a CDC let the
country down in terms of testing I think
they work very hard don't forget they've
been here for many years it's not they
don't work for me they work for the
country they've they've worked very hard
we when we took over in terms of you
know getting involved Mike headed up the
task force he worked with CDC and I
could ask Mike to give you a part you
know part of it but I will say they
originally they had no test and one of
the tests had a problem very early on
but that was quickly remedied and now we
have the best tests anywhere in the
world I think we give ourselves a lot of
that credit a lot of the brilliant
people that worked on testing a lot of
the brilliant people that worked on the
ventilators to a point where we have the
best testing in the world we have the
best ventilators and distribution and
the most ventilators in the world it's
not even close so I can't tell I would
like to ask Mike that question CDC you
work with them all the time certainly
much more than I do Mike oh we do mr.
president and let me say I think I think
Peter Navarro's point was that CDC and
our public health labs at the state
level were operating with an arcane
testing system and it was one of the
reasons why early on we brought in all
of the commercial labs around the
country the president created a
consortium of these commercial lab
and we reinvented testing in America
that's the reason why at the end of
February we had done a total of 84
hundred tests at that time using state
public labs and the CDC labs but because
of the president's efforts with with
basically innovating testing in America
we now reached 11 million tests you
heard the statistics more than 400,000
tests yesterday and we're actually
hearing as the president said earlier
we're hearing reports of excess capacity
that I think the state of New York
Governor Cuomo reportedly has the
ability to test 15,000 people a day but
they were only testing 5,000 people
where we've heard the same reports from
Florida and other states around the
country but again it's all a testament
of the fact that President Trump
essentially brought in the power of the
private marketplace private laboratories
reinvented testing in America and that's
how we've been able to be at a place
where as we talked about opening up
America every state in America today has
the testing capacity and the supplies to
be able to move into phase 1 reopening
and we're gonna continue to make that a
reality we've made a lot of Governors
look very good that I can tell you I'm
reading some of the reviews and some of
the governors and they're getting these
reviews well we were able to get on
ventilators that they didn't have we
were able to get them testing that they
still wouldn't have we were able to get
him a lot of things that they didn't
have including helping fill up their
stockpiles who which really they should
have had done they didn't they weren't
supposed to be using us for that but
we've met a lot of Governors look very
good and that's frankly good because
it's good for our country ok to speak to
the World Health Organization earlier
their virtual meeting today I chose not
to make a statement today I'll be giving
them a statement sometime in the near
future but I chose not to give a
statement I think they've done a very
sad job in the last period of time and
again the United States pays them 450
million dollars a year China pays them
38 million dollars a year
and there are puppet of China there
China centric to put it nicer but
they're a puppet of China and I think
they've done a very even when I did the
band my career members is very well when
I did the band they thought it was
inappropriate to do I did a band very
early if I didn't do that band you would
have lost hundreds of thousands of more
people in this country it was a very
important band people don't like talking
about the band but it was very important
I was the only one that wanted to do it
and we did it and we saved thousands of
lives hundreds of thousands of lives
probably and doctor foul Qi said that
and other people said that Deborah said
that you know that but the World Health
Organization was against it they were
against me too in the band they were
against they said you don't need it it's
too much it's too severe it's too all of
these things and they turned out to be
wrong sleepy Joe Biden said the same
thing he came out he said I was in a
phobic you believe that one Tilghman I
was in a phobic because I said you can't
come in if you come from China you can't
come into our country very early and
Biden said I was xenophobic town in San
Francisco at the same time we always got
along did with the twins they call us so
no it's it's a verse said a very same
thing so I'm not happy with the World
Health Organization and guess what
there's some of the people around this
table would understand being in business
in some cases international I'm not
happy with the World Trade Organization
at all either
wait sir why you decided to fire the
Inspector General of the State
Department yeah I don't know him at all
I never even heard of him
but I was asked to by the State
Department by Mike I offered most of my
people almost all of them I said you
know these are Obama appointees and if
you'd like to let him go I think you
should let him go but that's up to you
he's an Obama employee I understand he
had a lot of problems with the DoD there
was an investigation on him on the
inspector general I don't know what I
think about it so I don't know him I'd
never heard of him but they asked me to
terminate him I have the absolute right
as president to term
I've said who appointed him and they
said President Obama I said look I'll
terminate him I don't know what's going
on other than that but you'd have to ask
Mike Pompeo what they did ask me to do
it and I did it I have the right to
terminate the Inspector General's and I
would have I would have suggested and I
did suggest in pretty much all cases you
get rid of the Attorney General's
because it happens to be very political
whether you like it or not and many of
these people were Obama appointments and
so I just got rid of them and you've got
some criticism from Democrats in
Congress who are saying this is a
pattern of you trying to avoid having
accountability and if I didn't fire them
they would have criticized me too they
criticize no matter what you do you know
if you have too many ventilators they'll
say gee it's too many ventilators if you
don't have enough they'll say doesn't
have enough no matter what you do
between that and their partner the fake
news media they'll find something no I
don't know the gentlemen I was happy to
do it Mike
requested that I do it he should have
done it a long time ago in my opinion
he's an Obama appointment and he had
some difficulty but I just don't know
who he is I really I don't know it never
heard his name you believe there is a
role for Inspector General's to keep an
administration like the or have anyone
else's accountable sure but I think they
have to be fair and I think it's a death
wish when you and I told my people I
said I think you should you know study
your situation but let us know I think
we've been treated very unfairly by
Inspector General's I can go into
instances but I'm not going to do it now
but the Inspector General's when they're
put in by Obama just like it could be
that if they were put in by me and it
was somebody else's administration
especially the other party it could very
well be that you'd be treated unfairly
but we've had a lot of cases where we
thought that was unfair
so yeah they asked me to do that I think
the big thing is that they should have
asked me to do it a long time ago said
you don't know him sir what was he doing
that with treating you unfairly I don't
know I don't know I think about him I
don't know I don't know anything about
him other than the State Department and
Mike in particular I guess they weren't
happy with the job he's doing
or something so because it's my right to
do it I said sure I'll do it I've gotten
rid of a lot of Inspector General's
every president has I think every
president has gotten rid of probably
more than I have a lot of our people
kept the Obama inspector general and I
think generally speaking that's not a
good thing to do but they've kept him
but I told them for three years I said
anybody wants to get rid of their
Inspector General's because they were
appointed by President Obama I think you
should do so some of them didn't but now
they're doing couple of them are doing
it now yeah sir president isn't there at
least an appearance of a conflict of
interest if Secretary of Pompeo is
asking you to fire an inspector general
I don't think so I think maybe he thinks
he's being treated unfairly again he
wanted to he asked me if that would be
possible I said I'll do that sure I
think it should have been done a long
time ago frankly and this is a man that
has had some controversy this inspector
general but so again I don't know and I
think I haven't even read much about him
I see that it's a little bit of a story
not much of a story because everybody
agrees that I have the absolute right to
fire the Inspector General's I think
they should have done it a long time ago
yes please expect the recovery to be a
little bumpy you could take a look take
a little while are you forecasting a
faster bounce-back I think they're
forecasting a very fast bounce-back I
mean I see great optimism
these are big restaurant people that are
really up on the business they're very
successful they've been very successful
they'll be I think even more successful
again especially if we get deductibility
and know I really enjoyed this this was
a long meeting for me you know normally
I wouldn't say at a meeting this long
Tilghman but I like hearing about you're
a great basketball team I didn't know
those guys got paid for tea I thought
they've made 25 that's interesting
therefore for the record for my casino
in Louisiana opened up today and it
opened up extremely extremely busy in
Louisiana so so that's good to know that
people are coming out so that's great
what you do works you know I've watched
you for a long time and what you do
works we're very proud of you I
appreciate you
genuinely surprised about this PPP
extension proposal why was I surprised
you made that that asked for it it's a
private thing of course it's only us for
actually I know too many of these people
I'm surprised that's all I asked for no
I think what they're asking for is very
reasonable stick you know I mean we're
gonna have to go and get it approved and
again we was we've saved and we'll
continue to save the restaurant business
and ultimately we'll be paid back many
many times because they pay a lot of
taxes you know and they really they
create tremendous numbers of jobs think
of that you know 600 650 thousand
restaurants who would think that's even
possible in a final decision to fully
defund the W our contribution of the WHL
going forward well I have a concept
because we paid four hundred and fifty
thousand and somebody came out because
we have different ideas one was that I
mean I could ask these brilliant people
so we helped fund the World Health
Organization we use it like everyone
else does they gave us a lot of very bad
advice terrible advice they were wrong
so much always on the side of China
China paid 40 million dollars last year
and we've been paying 450 million
dollars a year for many years somehow
that doesn't work out too well so I was
thinking about bringing our 450 down to
40 and some people thought that was too
much so we're gonna make a decision
fairly soon but I think it's very unfair
when we're paying 454 many many years
we've been paying 300 400 450 almost 500
sometimes and and we're not treated
right and we're not treated by world
trade were not treated right either the
World Trade Organization China there is
considered a developing nation if you're
a developing nation you get massive tax
advantages and other advantage as well I
want the United States to be a
developing nation then okay we should
get the same advantages as China gets
why should Gina get advantages over the
United States because they got somebody
to say they're a developing nation and
so that's under review also
secretary Pompeo was reportedly under
investigation both for having staffers
do personal errands like walking this
dog and picking up his dry cleaning and
and concerns that he may have server to
the will of Congress with Saudi deals
with Saudi arms deals are you concerned
that he may have made this request to
avoid investigate well I don't think
about it I heard about at the same time
maybe you heard about it I don't know I
think about it I mean you mean he's
under investigation because he had
somebody walk his dog from the
government I don't know
doesn't say I don't think it sounds like
that important I mean you have a man
that's supposed to be and he's a
brilliant guy number one at West Point
number one at Harvard I believe Harvard
Law School are close and but he was
number one at West Point number one at
Harvard Law School or very close to
number one and they're bothered because
he's having somebody walk his dog as
you're telling me I didn't know that I
didn't hear that I didn't know about an
investigation but this is what you get
with the Democrats here's a man supposed
to be negotiating war and peace with
major major countries with weaponry like
the world has never seen before and the
Democrats and the fake news media
they're interested in a man who's
walking their dog and maybe he's busy
and maybe he's negotiating with Kim
jong-un okay about nuclear weapons so
that he'd say please could you walk my
dog do you mind walking my dog I'm
talking to Kim jong-un or I'm talking to
President Xi about paying us for some of
the damage they've caused to the world
and to us please walk my dog to who a
Secret Service person or somebody right
I don't know I think this country has a
long way to go they think the priorities
are really screwed up when I read this
down I don't know anything about the
investigation but you just tell me about
walking the dog and what you say doing
dishes Saudi arms deals sir what Saudi
arms deals explain past Congress passed
a law to restrict sales to Saudi Arabia
over certain arms
yes urn over there you see many crisis
so the question is whether secretary
Pompeii I tried to subvert the the deal
with actions that he may have taken on I
don't think so I mean I think that when
somebody pays us a fortune for you know
arms we should get the deal done I will
tell you that I don't I don't know what
you're talking about I know this that we
have countries that want to buy our arms
and we make it so difficult for them
that they end up going to Russia and
China and under my administration if
they're friendly countries I try and
make it as easy as possible if they want
to buy our fighter jets and if they want
to give us billions and billions of
dollars and they have other alternatives
including China Russia and others I
think we should make it as easy as
possible for them and we should take the
jobs and take the money cuz it's
billions of dollars and in past
administrations they waited so long the
people wouldn't even want to do business
with us and one of the things that we've
done and we make the greatest equipment
in the world by far and especially now
under this administration because we've
upped the scale a lot as you know and we
bought a lot we've totally rearmed our
military 1.5 trillion dollars but if
somebody wants us to give us billions of
dollars to buy an airplane or a number
of airplanes and missiles and all of the
other things that we make better than
anybody in the world we should take the
money we should make the deals fast I
would certainly say that even if it
leads to human rights
what if you take your mask off you know
you just for a second please
don't worry about Jeff Jeff why don't
you move out of his way so he doesn't
infect you please sure you want there to
become an effective even if it results
in human rights abuses that was
Congress's concern with these human
rights
I don't know that I don't know I mean
you know you tell me something that I
never heard if now you're talking about
human rights abuses you'll figure
something out I'm sure look he's a high
quality person Mike he's a very high
quality very brilliant guy and now I
have you telling me about dog walking
washing dishes and you know what I'd
rather have him on the phone with some
world leader than have him wash dishes
because maybe his wife isn't there or
his kids are that you know what are you
telling me it's terrible it's so stupid
you know stupid that sounds to the world
unbelievable okay yeah I think he was an
incompetent president I think President
Obama was one of the worst presidents in
the history of our country I think he
was an incompetent president I know what
he left us he left us a broken military
he left us a military that Isis was all
over the place and I got rid of it I did
I'd knocked out a hundred percent of the
caliphate and even you will admit that
John and when I came in it was a mess
but we had a broken military we had a
depleted military we had little on the
shelves if you talk about pandemics we
had a country that was a mess we were
paying high taxes we were paying and
outside of this artificial event that
took place two months ago and I'm gonna
build the country into stronger and
better than it was even then and it's
already happening and you can see it you
can see it today just take a look at the
stock market look at what's going on
look at the great numbers that are being
called and look at these medical
companies calling in and we're talking
about more than one so many things are
happening but I think President Obama
was an incompetent president he did a
terrible job and by the way there was
great division in our country with
President Obama you didn't see it as
much but there was tremendous division
in our country colleges division now too
I think you know success Springs we had
a great success going things we're
really going along and then China gave
us a wonderful gift okay and it wasn't
pretty what it came out of China just in
case you had any questions John it
didn't come out of came out of China
spread to Europe but also came here and
the whole world became infected by this
horrible thing that they unleashed one
way or the other not a good situation
not a good situation I'm not a man that
likes taking that what happened to us
and it was totally preventable they
could have stopped it at the source they
knew it was happening we wanted to go in
others wanted to go in they wouldn't let
they wouldn't let the world as you know
they wouldn't let they wouldn't let
other other countries go in they want it
other countries wanted to world health
wanted
in all fairness to world health they
woulda let world health it and we're a
part of world health they wouldn't let
them men either they could have stopped
it at the source and they chose not to
and yet they stopped them from going to
Wuhan into different parts of China so
you couldn't go into Beijing what do you
think of that tilman you couldn't go
into china but I better not get you
involved in a China thing you got enough
problems with stretc in China are back
though I'm an excellent business I'm
asking the an interesting guy that
question but seriously look they
wouldn't let him into China but they'd
let him into Europe and they'd let him
into all over the world including the
United States lucky I did the band
that's all I can tell you it's lucky I
did the band okay how about one or two
more yeah responsibility I'm going to
tell you that question why would I tell
you go ahead we we take steps to hold
charity held responsible for what
they've done they have hurt the world
very very badly they've hurt themselves
also but they've hurt the world very
very badly yeah they should be held
responsible okay tweeted recently that
this whole whistleblower racket needs to
be looked at I had a fake whistleblower
sure I think whistleblower originally he
was a faker because when he looked at my
he wrote down a conversation that was
totally different from the conversation
I actually had with the president of
Ukraine it was a fake whistleblower and
by the way everybody knows who he is
he's a political operative you know that
John knows who he is you know him better
than anybody John right he's a faker and
he was a fake whistleblower and it was a
phony disgraceful period of time and we
came out well you know why we came out
well because everyone recognized that
for what it was just a political
witch-hunt
but he was a fake whistleblower he wrote
a story that bore no resemblance to the
conversation that I had with the
president of Ukraine nothing whatsoever
and by the way the Inspector General he
went by the whistleblower he didn't want
to
the conversation that I had when he saw
the conversation that I had he said well
that bears no resemblance to what the
whistleblower said why did he look first
before he ran to Congress he ran to
Congress like he couldn't get there fast
enough with a whistleblower report but
when they offered him to see the actual
conversation and we called the head of
Ukraine and we said we'd like to expose
the conversation that we had if you
don't mind he said what was wrong with
that that conversation as I say was
perfect it was a perfect conversation
not a thing said wrong that's why we had
other than half a vote from Romney and
Romney's you know loser but other than a
half of what we had from Romney I got
fifty two and a half percent to a half
in the house we got 196 to nothing 196
to nothing the Republicans were so
unified not because they all liked me
but because they knew this was a
horrible thing that happened but he was
a fake whistleblower he reported on a
conversation that didn't happen just
like shifty Schiff shifty Schiff went up
before Congress and because he has
immunity in other words you can't put
him in jail but if he lies and from
because they have immunity in the halls
of counter and that great hall so he
made a statement that was totally
different from what I said you know that
eight times
quid pro quo there were no quid pro quos
nothing zero eight times over and over
again and he made it as though that was
the conversation but he knew that was in
the conversation I had and anyplace else
he would have been thrown out of office
and put in jail for what he did but he
had immunity because he made it in the
halls should be the opposite if you make
a statement like that if you lie in car
you should get double penalties okay so
you know that's the way it goes so you
had a phony whistleblower and this other
guy with the hydroxychloroquine okay
well he he went out and he's the one
that approved the hydroxychloroquine
he's the one that signed the application
he also happens to be if you look
see whether or not I won't put it on me
I'll put it in you see whether or not he
was a big contributor to the Democrats
see whether or not he wanted the
Democrats to win no it's a lot of bad
things coming out about him but you
people don't want to write the the news
you know but if you look but he's the
one that signed the application the very
important form he signed it now if he
doesn't believe in it why would he sign
it and a lot of good things have come
out about the hydroxy a lot of good
things have come out and you'd be
surprised at how many people are taken
and especially the frontline workers
before you catch it
the frontline workers many many are
taking it I happen to be taking it I
happen to be taking it hydroxy Cory I'm
taking it hydroxychloroquine right now
yeah a couple of weeks ago I started
taking it because I think it's good I've
heard a lot of good stories and if it's
not good I'll tell you right I'm not
gonna get hurt by it it's been around
for 40 years from malaria for lupus for
other things I take it
frontline workers take it a lot of
doctors take excuse me a lot of doctors
take it I take it now I hope to not be
able to take it soon because you know I
hope they come up with some answer but I
think people should be allowed to I got
a letter from a doctor the other day
from Westchester New York around the
area he didn't want anything he just
said sir I have hundreds of patients and
I give them hydroxychloroquine I give
them the z-pak which is Z through my
send and I give them zinc and out of the
hundreds of patients many hundreds over
300 patients I haven't lost one he said
please keep pressing that sir and if you
look at that phony report that was put
in that report on the hydroxy was given
to people that were an extraordinarily
bad condition extraordinarily bad people
that were dying no I I think for
whatever it's worth I take it I was i I
would have told you that three four days
ago but we never had a chance because
you never asked me the question the
White House did the White House doctor
recommend that you take that is that why
you're a White House doctor didn't
no I asked him what do you think you
said well if you'd like it and said yeah
I'd like it I'd like to take it a lot of
people are taking a lot of frontline
workers that taking hydroxychloroquine a
lot of front I don't take it because hey
people said oh maybe he owns the company
no I don't know the company you know
what I want the people of this nation to
feel good I don't want them being sick
and there's a very good chance that this
has an impact especially early on but
you look at frontline workers you look
at doctors and nurses a lot of them are
taking it as a preventative and they're
taking totally unrelated but they take
the z-pak or the xethru Meissen for
possible infection now I haven't taken
that other than an original dose because
the all you need you don't have to take
it simultaneously but the zinc you do
take so I'm taking the to the zinc and
the hydroxy and all I can tell you is so
far I seem to be ok why you started
taking it have you been excused no no
not at all I just said that I've had so
many letters from people like the one I
told you about I got it last week I'll
give you would you like a copy of it I'd
love to give you a v/s kabali she'll
give you a copy of it but this is a
doctor he doesn't want anything I don't
know I've never heard of him but he
treats people that are that we're
talking about and he said out of
hundreds of people that he's treated he
hasn't lost one and he just wanted me to
know about it that's all it wasn't he
wasn't saying gee can I have dinner with
you mr. president I'd like to come to
the White House but I've received many
such letters I've received a lot of
positive letters and it seems to have an
impact and maybe it does maybe it
doesn't but if it doesn't you're not
going to get sick or die this is a pill
that's been used for a long time for
3040 years on the malaria and on lupus
too and even on arthritis I guess from
what I understand so it's been heavily
tested in terms of I was just waiting to
see your eyes light up when I said this
but you know what I announced this but
yeah I've taken it for about a week and
a half now and I'm still here I'm still
here
can you explain sir though you what
is the evidence that it has a
preventative thank you are you ready
here's my evidence I get a lot of
positive calls about it
the only negative I've heard was the
study where they gave it was it the VA
with you know people that aren't big
Trump fans gave it and we've done the
greatest job maybe of anything in the VA
because I got VA choice and VA
accountability both approved
accountability Tillman is where you can
fire bad people that work in the VA that
you couldn't fire them we had thousands
of people that were sadists that was
stealing that were robbers that were
horrible people
they'd beat up our veterans they
couldn't do it in primetime but they did
it when they were sick and we got
accountability nobody thought you could
get it because of the unions and civil
service
I got it passed so that now you fire bad
people in the VA we got rid of
tremendously bad people that should
never been there but I also got probably
even more importantly if you can say
that maybe not VA choice so if you have
to wait on line for a doctor you go
outside you have a private doctor we pay
the bill we work out deals with doctors
we have pricing so you go out you pay
the bill and it was a great thing that
we did so we've done a great job with
the VA but they had a report come out
and the results of the report it was
very unscientific report by the way but
I get a lot of tremendously positive
news on the hydroxy and I say hey you
know the expression I've used John what
do you have to lose okay what do you
have to lose so I have been taking it
for about a week for about a week and a
half at some point every day I take a
pill every day at some point I'll stop
what I'd like to do is I'd like to have
the cure and or the vaccine and that'll
happen I think very soon zero symptoms
no I haven't had any said no I tested a
test every couple of days they want to
test me you know for obvious reasons I
mean I am the president so they want to
test me I don't want to be tested but
they want to test me so every couple of
days I get tested and I've been I've
shown always negative right negative is
that the term you use for this right
negative
totally negative no
symptoms no nothing but no I take it
because I think I hear very good things
again you have to go to frontline
workers many frontline workers take it
and they seem to be doing very well
vice-president pens for your family no
one would be surprised I don't want to
ask them because that's a personal
decision as to whether or not you want
to say I just want to be open with the
American public because you know I
happen to think it's good I do want the
letter given because this letter made
not in terms of my taking it but I
thought it was a very well-crafted
letter by a man who's a respected doctor
up in Westchester maybe a little beyond
Westchester a little up higher and in
New York and he just he didn't want
anything he just wanted me to know the
results of what he's doing as a doctor
and he was so happy with the fact that I
I fight for this stuff and then we have
this crazy whistleblower this fake
whistleblower get out and try and you
know knock it who is to signed the
application he did all this deed into
signing he was a believer at one point I
assume otherwise he shouldn't have
signed it no matter who told him to he
shouldn't have signed it okay one more
question that's it thank you all very
much thank you fellas thank you
hey Tillman Thank You Man you take care
of you
in normal times I shake your hand and
hug you
saying load every